hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and I'm John Humphrey so we're gonna
watch three videos uploaded from the
Star Wars channel within the last week o
couple TV spots one a super short pink
featurette on a new design by the way
page from the day shout-out gonna go out
to jay and Valente keep a lookout bud
stir let's start off with the first one
they release which is called tenth ooh
it's where ray is in the Garden of Eden
she's hungry for that Apple and star
wars snake comes by looks like snake
this little ship
[Music]
right
[Music]
dude really like the direction of the
promos here really teasing that Ray is
we at least know for sure she's being
tempted by the dark something powerful
and sinister yeah yeah that this is the
plot line I'm most intrigued by out of
everything they've shown us from Star
Wars of what's to unfold potentially in
this movie you know she's gonna
encounter Snoke at one point you know
Finn's gonna wake up and then it going
up against fast but there's a little and
in that scene with Leia and kylo Ren
there's a lot of things to look forward
to here but this seems like this is
gonna be the most personal aspect of the
story that we see in this movie so I'm
super super stoked to watch or just be
tempted yeah and this version of this
the two towers that's the Frodo and Sam
story and everyone else okay all those
fights we thought we were gonna get all
this like matchups we're gonna get with
cool new characters now it's gonna have
this looks pretty thrilling okay let's
look at this one this is the evolution
of the crystal fox which you see a
little tease of in the last teaser we
saw yeah
[Music]
25,000 crystals
[Music]
and then we will make a perfect version
of CG I will then scan it to be able to
bring that to life you know how you do
it
[Music]
that's cool
III mentioned on the my Justice League
second viewing I feel like no one ever
really points how good CGI yeah there
are tons of yeah very hard-working
talented artists even if they're not
amazing it's still like impressive yeah
you know I feel like if you see a
trailer you're more likely to point out
good CGI I feel like when you walk out
of a movie I usually hear especially in
LA people [ __ ] about the scenes of it
thought were bad CGI sometimes the
points are valid but I'm like how come
the same person bitching about the bat
is not pointing out when the CGI looks
good and scenes you know I guess that
thing we're like if it's good enough
it's it's supposed to look like it's not
even there yeah I know but there's other
scenes though in the same movies that
have great CGI at times but no one
points that [ __ ] out I really need a rag
on because like the way we use it - it's
like it's easier to tell when everything
about a scene or everything that a
certain character is not real well this
I think is the best blend of it because
I respect the hell out of
computer-generated effects and I'm more
drawn of course the practical effects
especially when you're dealing with Star
Wars because that's a big part of what
made it so special was those practical
effects designs back in like the 70s 80s
and that's part of true movie magic who
is bringing that stuff to life not yes
painting it in later but this helps the
CGI look even more real because you know
there was a practical effect and then
the digital touches on it and smooth it
out a little bit more for the motions
and whatnot for every scene that the
crystal fox is featured in now the
question is what the hell is crystal fox
exactly yeah how are they gonna figure
into this they look like they're
probably benevolent creatures but who's
to say and are they that important of a
creature or is this just like a teaser
like here's a cool or is this gonna be
like oh yeah Crystal Foxes doesn't
really matter in this movie which like
I'm actually excited to see that
specifically now because of this yeah
cuz we did an old show for Fangoria and
Nerdist called blood and guts where we
went to like effects houses and I
remember you would see certain creations
that would look amazing and they're
these like suits and puppets ever built
and then you know they say yeah did you
look at the movie and you can barely
even see it and they painted over them
with CGI and stuff
it's cool to see when like you've got an
actual creature like that that can
articulate and say yeah they're probably
gonna use it well hell yeah
crystal fox looking forward to it all
right last teaser it's called back back
back back okay like John has terrible
back pain this mofo got my back I do or
I'm gonna stab him in the back that's
not cool Morty we gotta get back to the
future or Eminem being like guess who's
back it's call back its back
[Music]
it's good to have that tease when you
get all these trailers that are so
serious and heavy oh yeah a relic Star
Wars music the thing that gets you
excited when the opening scroll appears
you changed that song it wouldn't be as
exciting you know to hear these
triumphant Star Wars music show it over
the imagery I'm hoping this film can
capture both pretty well yeah because
right now a lot of the trailers are very
serious trailers which I love I love it
I do I love the hell out I'm gonna have
some weight and some heft at the same
time you know I
there was a heroes teaser I saw that I
was really drawn to and I'm gonna want
that in my movie yeah yeah yeah
for this particular franchise I don't
have much of a reason right now to feel
like those won't both be there yes you
know you look back at the old Star Wars
films there are some more dramatic
elements but then you know each has its
you know young triumphant adventure
parts like when Sebulba tampered with I
pod and totally messed up his playlist
before the big race and he almost caused
Anakin to lose the race which is really
my fan theory as to why he went to the
dark side yeah yeah yeah just couldn't
cope with failure
he won that's right but didn't like the
obstacle I'm so used to losing that
video game Star Wars we got our tickets
I'm gonna watch it twice for sure
I can't wait I can't work I'll watch it
at least the first time guys
pitch from the day shop for Jane Valente
Jane Valente lo you have a letter for
you we have a letter for you we
delivered it to the address and gave us
then I get this Instagram message from
this account run by two lovely beautiful
women and I was like why are two
beautiful women messaging me the only
two beautiful woman to message me I'm a
mom and sister my girlfriend
would you really call her a woman that
makes me look bad not really my
girlfriend is quite a sexy kid you know
what I mean that's what she has she's
lewd she's a cat what I wanted to tell
you but he was you got to get back to us
on patreon man I've been trying to get
ahold of you for like a month now or
waving at you
and I've sent you lost three messages at
least and then the other day instead of
replying back and giving us your correct
address get pledge for a higher reward
tier that allows you to get one of our
shirts we can't Merrill the shirt to you
we can't send anything to you until you
messages back we don't have a peel box
right now so no we gotta make sure it
gets to you so please messages back
other than that you're wonderful he's
got a mess back appreciate the
contributions and everything we're do
you know if you watch any of our videos
on patreon no idea what cuz of you that
you can watch them really helpful
subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell you can
follow us on social media but make sure
to especially follow us in Stardust's
app download and follow us there a lot
of your favorite youtubers are
definitely using it allows you to do
30-second reactions for any film TV show
and trailer and perfectly suited for us
since I know most you click off after
the reaction anyway so watch it over
there or follow us you know what I meant
to say bye